the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we recap of the last lecture what we
talked about is the wave ledger we
particle duality starting Punk Einstein
relations energy is related frequency
momentum is ready to the wavelength of
the particle and that laid the
foundation for the wave particle duality
although Einstein focused on his effort
on the photons in the hung this was
extended to they see the mature waves
and for mature waves will have different
ways to describe it their different
approaches matrix approach the operator
approach but the one that I use here is
the Schrodinger equation that says they
describe this wave function which is the
function of time and space and the we
function on the left-hand side
essentially this is the like at your
kinetic energy this is a potential
energy and the right-hand side is a time
dependent term and the solution as we'll
see in today's lecture of this equation
will give you a wave type of solution
and uh what's interesting is the meaning
of this wave function was not clear at
the time that this equation was written
down so the it turns out that the
explenation correct explanation of the
wave function we function itself is a
complex number doesn't have physical
meaning but the we function times
complex conjugate will give a real
library and this gives the probability
of finding this material wave a certain
time and location so this is the
explanation given by born and that
create a lot of trouble because that
means
is uncertain in the quantum world is
probability so there is an expectation
value they the mean value and there is
also standard deviation and that
standard deviation net who the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle we
commented in the last lecture and then
we did a little bit maths we say okay
let's do a separation of variable
because this will be function is the
function of time and space as long as
this u potential energy the constraint
this material wave so the equation is if
you look at it so the first term is the
kinetic energy and second term is the
potential energy and what's differ for
each problem is really this potential
energy that constraints are different so
if u is not dependent on time then we
can do separation variable to separate
the wave function into a space part and
the time part time part was easy you can
easily solve it and turns out that
separation of variable constant ye has a
physical meaning and that minute is the
energy of the system and with that we
substitute into from this time-dependent
equation we can get the steady state
equation where the steady state is space
dependent part of the wave function can
be determined and you will see that this
is actually a eigenvalue equation it's
here here on the right hand side zero so
what you actually use is not only find
the wave function but also find the
eigen value of the energy of the system
so this will put a constraint on the
possible energy of the system that's
where the energy quantization word
naturally came up so this is a where we
were in the last lecture and today we
will use this equation and give a few
simple solutions
so today what
we'll go in first I will give you
example solutions and if you recall in
the first two lectures we talked about
what's the energy alpha or molecule
right we have kinetic energy we have
vibrational energy rotational energy
electronic energy and I'm going to use
the quantum mechanics roading equation
to see what are they storing go to in
the quantum mechanics impose on this
energy forms and the quantization and
then from this we will see the important
one
some important concept what is the
quantum state and what are they
degenerate sees and if you recall that
we talked about the the counting right
we see okay how many particles we have
and this degeneracy is an important step
in doing the correct accounting when we
later on to the transport problem so
account of how much energy the system
really has so let's start with the
example solutions
and we said the difference for each
problem is really that potential you'll
write the first part is the kinetic
energy is say once you know the mass
that's the term you have and each
problem each particle is constrained by
different potentials right our air
molecule in this room electron in a film
or the vibration energy those are
different potential constraints right so
let's look hide up first
the simplest one there is no potential
no constraint a free particle a complete
free and let's look at 1d so we don't
need to write the three dimension so 1d
free particle what does that tell you so
ah we have already the time dependent
term right and so we only need to go to
find out from the steady state the space
dependent term by combined together we
know what's the wave function and if
it's free there's no constraint this you
the potential energy is zero everywhere
and so my steady state equation if you
copy that into 1d is mass h-bar squared
to M D psi DX minus r e+ i equals zero
e is the energy of this particle the
eigen value of the problem and this
equation i think you can all solve it
let's go one more step I put them
together this constants so what I have
is a K square plus I equal to zero
well this K square is 2m
at e / H bar square right it's just a
location for my cake and I solve this
equation second order differential
equation with constant coefficient K not
a space dependent term right that's the
easy one so you find the card ristic
root of this terrific equation that's
plus minus K so what we have is then
plus I X is a Ematic I KX plus b e plus
ikx do you agree that's the solution
right now we combine this space
dependent solution with the time
dependent solution - ie H bar I say
that's a time dependent right and ay yi
I say it's equal si is the energy e
equals H nu so I could write this right
so the wave function as a function of
time and space could be then written as
the explanation mass I Omega T up plus
KX plus B exponential minus I Omega t
minus KX
well this e equals H bar Omega H bar is
H over 2 pi so this is the angular
frequency rather than nu nu Omega is 2
pi nu right so that's the solution for
this pre-packed a free particle in space
from minus infinity to plus infinity
what you can say is this solution tells
you the particle is away this is tip
your wave right this is a wave propagate
into which the ration negative with the
direction X direction right omega t
minus KX here is omega t plus KX so you
have to counter propagating waves in
free space and let's go from minus
infinity to plus infinity particular is
everywhere right this is the uncertainty
for pre particle you can pinpoint where
it is okay and so that's the free
particle and basic it tells us it's a
wave and if you look at this K is the
wave vector right if you look at this
wave case weight vector and if I go to
combine and write a energy what's the
energy of this particle is H bar square
K square divided by 2m right here this
is my definition 4k K is the wave vector
okay I write the energy H Bar K go back
to the Einstein relation there are P
equals H lambda is h-bar K that's the
momentum so it comes back to essentially
the p square 2 m that's the kinetic
energy free particle right kinetic
energy momentum energy relation energy
equals one-half MV square right so this
is the 1d free particle and now let's
put a constraint on it right so ah 1d
quantum well
and we already went to the web and look
at the people actually working on
Commonwealth so the deposits in films
and in that case your electron in the
film is subject to the constraint
because outside the film is a vacuum or
another material right so now we give
the simplest potential form for a say
constraint simcha simple constraint so
here is the potential let's say this is
the day house this is the film if I
deposit a solid film and this is the
thickness is 0 to D right and potential
let's say I take this as 0 this as the
infinite right so that's a
simplification in the real tight real
case vacuuming may not be the difference
between vacuum and the film the energy
is a pretty much the work function of
the electron we said before right that's
a few electron volt so it's not a 0 to
infinite but ah for simplicity of my
solution here I say here is 0 potential
here is infinite potential ok so what is
the energy of electron or if it's a atom
somehow I constrain the atom between two
parallel plates right what's it
allowable energy if you recall our two
lectures ago we actually give a solution
without solving the Schrodinger equation
we say you have standing waves right so
we have 1/2 wavelengths the full
wavelength with that we found the energy
before and what we're going to do next
is using the Schrodinger q equation and
to derive the same result so here energy
is and here Y is 0 so for the 0 part
next
suppose I take my coordinate X is good
between zero and D so between zero and D
if you look high today Schrodinger
equation is essentially the same
equation right right because the
potential is zero and then outside this
region because protons are is the
infinite so what's the wave function
value this is infinite this has to be
zero right so my boundary condition is
essentially I this two point we function
zero and in between my solution is here
so I'm going to use this boundary
condition use the solution we have so we
have the solutions here I'm going to not
to repeat that solution and in this case
we have x equals zero wave function
should be zero and that helps me here
when x equals 0 this is 0 this is this
is 1 this is 1 a plus B equals 1 so I
have a plus B equals 1 that's the first
of 0 sorry a plus B equals 0
thank you yep and X squares for D wave
function 0 again so I have a a
exponential minus ikx plus t i KD plus B
X venture plus i KD equal 0 right so a
equals mass B so if we'll a equals must
be a substitute in this what I have I
take the out I will have a
negative to a I sign KD equal zero right
after I substitute the first a equals
minus B that's what I have
okay so I cannot have a equals to 0 B
equals zero if I have that my wave
function 0 I have nothing there right so
my only way to have this meaning for is
sine K D equals 0 and that means a times
D now has to be interviewed C right sine
k D equals 0 plus R PI 2 pi right every
to every PI so I have now I have to put
a subscript n because this is the N
times pi and the N could be 0 plus minus
1 plus minus 2 so those are the
mathematical solutions okay
and this mathematical solution tells me
K n now is quantized right K n is n PI
over D and the KN is 2m e n H bar square
so 2m e n H bar square so my energy
becomes discrete right so from here I
solve for the energy of this particle
eCourse uh-oh
should I yeah square root 1/2 and I
square that so it's a pie square n
square and H bar Square and
a 2m d squared so this is the energy
solution for the particle in the in the
old days it was it called Patagonian Box
in that one dimensional box right and
this is a comment before with the
simplest quantizer solution and it was
simply a homework right the first
possible mathematical demonstration the
simplest one and by say in the 70s
people starting actually named on
atomically flat film and to realize
those simple solutions and now it
becomes a very standard as you can you
see from the last time we show from
website a lot of people doing this
quantum well using this energy
quantization to make a lasers particular
okay
and if you substitute it because the
last time we we use the H so if you
substitute H equals H by cross H 2 PI
over 2 pi you'll find that solution is
identical to what we gave before so the
last time I solve this problem we set
the energy quantization without any real
OC solving the equation and now we solve
the equation we show that's the
identical so this is the eigenvalue and
of course with the eigenvalue we can
also to go to say for each n there is
also a corresponding Phi n the wave
function right and it's important I
carry this n number they quantize the
the quantum number and so here Phi n you
substitute back into the solution here I
equals months B what we have the mass to
I a
and the sy n PI x over D okay and from
this you will say and it should not be 0
if n is 0 again wavefunction is
everywhere is 0
there's no particle there right and the
symmetry also tells me what really is
meaningful is N equals positive 1 2 3 so
that's the LCD the quantum number N and
how to determine this a the Lomo lies a
ssin right so because this is a
probability so the probability of
finding the particle between 0 to D is
why because that's the outside is 0 and
inside must be somewhere so Milo
Malaysian is 0 to D plus I and times
simple sign and complex conjugate DX
that should be equal to 1
I'm not going through the math you can
find that a equals to i1 over to D and
that means the wave function equals 2
over D sine M PI x over D okay so if you
go to read a book ah the example given
in the book take this wave function go
to calculate what's the average momentum
what's the uncertainty in the momentum
and what's the position of the particle
what's uncertainty of the position of
the particle right because in the in the
example which I'm not going through you
will say from data you can actually show
this the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle is indeed the case of course
it should be in those examples ok so you
can take any of those n values and do
that ok so ah what I want to emphasize
this is a 1d problem one-dimensional
problem a 1d problem I get a one quantum
number N and what I'm going to Lex to
show you is if I go to a two dimensional
problem I'll get two quantum numbers
okay so I'm doing a simpler simple
extension of the same problem here is a
film right and Lexia is a wire this is
now people doing all nanotechnology from
film to wire to dot so it's a 1d 2d and
3d 3d is a 0 D because when you
constrain street dimension normally we
have 3d right bulk material but if you
constrain in three dimension becomes a
zero D problem so let's do a 2d problem
to the particle of quantum wire right so
again I do a square and if you want to a
cylinder you have to go to a cylindrical
coordinate right I'm not going to spend
much time on math I want to just tell
you the concept so let's say this is a
zero D I can do a square wire you can
also do a rectangular wire whatever and
outside is potential yo is again
infinite inside potential yo is zero
right so what's the energy of a particle
now inside this wire right and we can go
back and write down
the Schrodinger equation steady-state
Schrodinger equation outside this wire
because the potential is infinite wave
function is infinite
now you zero we found in zero and inside
U is 0 so I have 2d problem so I'm going
to write down the 2d differential
equation right so I have a partial
differential equation again let me move
this H bar square 2 m combined with the
e to get a case where so I'm jumping one
step I'm going to write the partial
differential equation into the steady
state part is so this is my x coordinate
this is my y coordinate i'm equals K
square plus I equal to 0 and this K
square is I get is 2m e uy by H bar
square that's the consequence I move
this to here this is the equation inside
this region and the boundary wave
functions are 0 right so for this
partial differential equation again
you'll find that K include the energy
energy of your lecturer eigen value of
the solution process and because the two
dimensional partial differential and the
way I do it
separation variable right so ah I do
want to go through it to show you get to
quantum numbers so this is the counting
the quantum states what is the quantum
state that concept so now I say ok my
wave function is a function of x and y
and I do separation of variables so I
separated into
a function X a function y and if I
substitute it into the original
differential equation I will get this is
substitute the N X DX plus y the Y
square plus K square equals zero right
this is after you substitute the wave
function into here you divide both sides
by this wave function and you say
because this is a function of X only so
this is a function y only this is the K
is the separation variable constant
right so your only way is this is a
constant this is a constant so that you
add up because this is a function y this
is a function of X this is a constant so
this each of this term has to be a
constant right so my location is I have
DX square equals minus KX square so this
is minus KX square mass KY square add up
together that gives me K square okay so
I have the first and if you look hi
today my boundary condition without my
boundary condition right at the a curve
x equals 0 plus I equals 0 that also
means this at 0 must be 0 because Y is
any value plus right and same I say X
square is P I have D equals 0 and you
can write y equals 0 this same argument
that will say y 0 is 0 why the
is zero and this problem now if you
check with this to boundary condition
this equation is identical to the to
what we had before
I didn't write it's really you go to
look at this solution with the same
boundary condition your solution is the
same so what we'll have based on this
boundary condition I'll get a sigh K X
times D equals 0 that's what we are
written down for one D promise sign KD
equals 0 in this one D now is the K in
the X Direction 0 and similarly you can
divide the ration why the ration apply
the same you will get a sine KY times D
equals 0 okay so those are the solution
requirement that impose my KX KY
okay so I'm going to
find the day what do we have now is K X
n that's my quantization number quantum
number equals n pi divided by D and this
is again a equals zero plus months 1 +
KY I don't use the same n because the to
the rations are independent right I use
a different integer L let's say and
that's L PI over D and this is l equals
0 plus minus 1 so after I substitute
back into a KX square plus KY squared
equals K square what I have K square is
2m e não é is a the quantum number
include both NL h square - y equal KX
square is the n pi over d square plus l
pi over d square so now you can say I
have two quantum number N and L because
I have a to the ration two degrees of
freedom and corresponding to this two
quantum number i will also have poss-eye
wave function l n equals a constant say
Ln and sine n PI x over D
sigh l pi y over D okay and again you
can use the low molestation condition to
find the coefficient that's not the
important what is important is now to
recognize that each set L and the N
right when l equals 1 N equals 2 so when
l equals 1 that's a half way in the x
direction or another
Ln I should do an L to be consistent
okay so when N equals 1 that's a half
way in x direction l equals 2 that's a
full way right foot here in the y
direction and now if I do N equals 2
that is a food purity in the X direction
and L cross Y is a high purity in y
direction so there are two different of
forms right two different quantum state
however the energy doesn't hear an
equals 1 l equals 2 or English 2 l
equals 1 right so this to quantum state
have the same energy
okay this is the degeneracy that
Quantum's this energy level is
degenerate so we have now the concept I
say what is a quantum state right each
wave function here is a quantum state
and then say some quantum state a
degenerate
when they have different quantum numbers
but same energy level okay and some of
you are familiar with the density of
states and this is the original density
of states it's just so when we have many
will contact more in the terms of 410
sub States rather than degenerating okay
so ah these are they all these
mathematics I'm going to use the rest
are for the solution I'm going to give
you right because they say you'll have
more partial differential more involved
solution of partial differential
equations but also I'm going to show you
my way of doing that without solving the
equation I can do that pretty much for
all the problems so I say that's my
contribution to quantum mechanics
because okay so let's look at some other
problems we see this one you can say
it's a partner in a box you can say it's
a quantum well quantum work on dots or
it's a model as an atom right it's a
translational energy so they is they say
kinetic energy pod is quantized and
let's look at other examples
we talked about before if I have a
diatomic atom like a hydrogen atom a
hydrogen molecule right diatomic
molecule then you have a vibrational
part of the energy you have rotational
part of energy right so let's first look
at the vibrational part if you have a
mass spring system right the force in
the harmonic Sprint picture we have will
say force linear proportional to
displacement right and we see the
problem each problem is different it's
because the potential so we need to find
the potential and the potential energy
is the derivative forces the derivative
of the potato
that's a always true right so from here
I say the potential energy is one-half
KX squared so this is the one that you
should put it in the steady state the
Schrodinger equation
that's your potential now you go to
solve that equation now you can see it's
a complicated because my Patricia is a
function of X my coefficient is no
longer constant so solving this equation
actually is a lot of effort you have to
go see a lot more math than the one that
we talked to before and let's see what
they end the result right it's a
one-dimensional problem right the
variable is X only so from that I have
one quantum number okay one degree of
freedom one quantum number and the
energy it turns out quantization one
quantum number equals
h nu n plus 1/2 and this new is not
different from a classical oscillator if
you have spring mass system what's the
frequency square root of K over m and
2pi so you could of course write this
h-bar Omega n plus 1/2 so you can see
now the difference between a quantum and
classical system is that say in a
closure system you're just arbitrarily
determined by the displacement amplitude
of this business in the quantum the
energy has to be multiple of this H nu
right that's the vibration or energy
quanta and this 1/2 is a zero-point
energy okay zero-point energy and it
turns out say this oscillator is also
valid for the lattice when we have a lot
of atoms in the solid and when we have
electromagnetic wave wave it's also
oscillator electromagnetic field
oscillator all the energy is this form
h-bar Omega n plus 1/2 and this 1/2 is a
reflection of the uncertainty principle
okay
and it's very interesting this
zero-point energy is also something that
related to the 1 watch force and some
people say even also relate to the
missing mass of the universe okay and
this there there there I can out comment
more on this later so we have this is
the harmonic oscillator
and the next one is reach the ruler so
what what I'm trying to do is is for
example is two hydrogen atom for
molecule right I see one mode of energy
storage energy is this atom vibrator
attitude to each other
that's vibrational that's harmonic
oscillator and the other way of storing
the energy is the by rotation of the
molecule right and so in that case I say
reach the ruler so you just decompose
the problem as fix the distance between
the atom they will rotate and how many
degrees of freedom here right the
distance is fixed so R is fixed and
they're only see the fight in space so I
have two degrees of freedom right so for
our rigid rotor going to have a mass m1
m2 and I fix the distance and the
rotation is related to the moment of
inertia which is the m1 m2 and R square
R zero squared so that's a separation
between the atoms m1 plus m2 okay and
now in terms of degree freedom we
function because it has two degree of
freedom the wave function is L and this
M is not mass when I use the subscript
here that's an integer okay
everybody use it so you have to
distinguish yourself
so LM are integers and of course we have
to because FC defy two degrees
of freedom right and I'm not going to
write this is a spherical coordinate
problem and that the solution is a
pretty complicated by the later are your
your CD I'll go to website and to show
you it's much better than I draw on the
board and so because of the wave
function two quantum number
I have also the energy but now the
energy is degenerate so I'm not using
the concept I just mention it turns out
the for I have a several combination of
L and M that can give you the same
energy e l energy only depends on L wave
function has two quantum numbers and so
II L M and you see it doesn't depend on
2i l l plus one doesn't depend on M
rotational energy level right and this
quantum number l equals zero one two and
that's a solution of the Schrodinger
equation in fact that in this case is
the angular momentum and M constraint is
the absolute value is less than L that's
equal to L okay so what does it have is
if you have wave function 0 0 l equals 0
M is only 0 right now if wave function l
equals 1 then M is mass 1 0 plus 1 right
equals to 1 minus 1/2 sine 1 0 cosine 1
1 you say this 3 wave function have the
same energy and to just give you a heads
up what this way function look like is a
dump
I'll ship ok and so now we have the
degeneracy of any energy level l quantum
number is 2 L plus 1 because here M is 2
L plus 1 right for any L I give M is 12
plus 1 that's my degeneracy so now I'm
counting the quantum state and the jit
degeneracy for energy levels okay and
this is the rotation we said ok first
one is translation vibration rotation
right if you think about Adam there's
another one that's the electronic okay
so let's go to the electronic energy
level
and the simplex electronic picture is a
I have a hydrogen atom right 1c proton
one electron so we have one nuclear we
nuclear is much more heavier than
electrons so you can be considered as
stationary and now the electron will
Abbott around the loop clean right so
before we see the force to turn to
charge
what's the force Coulomb force force
between two charged
okay so Q 1 Q 2 Q 1 Q 2 4 PI epsilon
that's the dielectric constant R square
right so here is the separation and of
course again if you integrate this you
get the potential right the potential is
the fourth derivative whether we read in
there right so the potential for this
problem U as a function of R is minus c1
R because the charge is opposite so
that's an essay and then there's a
negative side in the potential so when
they bound very close they go to lower
potential right so that's the direction
they're given this potential if you look
at this problem 1d or 3d problems
electron moving around the loo clean its
our it could be angular right so you
have three degrees of freedom and my
wave function is a function of R is
function of theta a function of Phi
spherical coding three dimensional and
then I'm expecting three quantum numbers
so I'm expecting three quantum number
and L M okay so now I have the three
quantum number and each set each
combination plant number give me one
quantum state but if you go to solve the
problem for energy eigenvalue you find
that depends endow me so although I have
many quantum state and then my energy e
n is a function so LM but it doesn't it
doesn't depend on the LM so what I have
is the mass of the electron C 1 square
and the two H bar square else work and
if you plug in the number you find this
one is thirteen point six electron volt
divided by n square so this is the our
energy depends on n only see the wave
function has three quantum number and
what are the constraints for those
quantum numbers here I have a integer 1
2 and L has to be l has to be less than
n has to be positive so when N equals 1
l equals 0
okay M is the same constraint I have for
this problem
so ah M is equal or less than L okay so
this is the energy level and if we look
at a wave function n equals equals 1 and
then I have l equals 0 1 0 0 right
increase 1 and then when I have N equals
2 L could be 0 in that case M is 0 right
or I can have wave function equals to L
cross 1 because when N equals 2 I have 0
1 and then in that case I have 2 1 0 to
1 1 okay so the degeneracy GN for any
let us say m value is n square n equals
1 is a one way function N equals 2
that's a full wave functions right but
say N equals to I have 1 energy I have
wood for wave function have the same
energy
ok so almost I'm almost here and Konkan
but before I do that I want to say my
way of solving the Schrodinger equation
I didn't solve it right so now I'm going
to show my hand waving way of solving
I'll give you one example and you can do
the others probably I said that in the
previously when we study our quantum
Wells the wave is either a half wave or
full wave that's my boundary condition
to form standing waves right so this one
we already gone through and we said
that's consistent just based on the
standing wave requirement when we do the
oscillator my potential is like this
right 1/2 KX squared that's my potential
we said that each problem
what distinguish the problem of energy
is real this potential and its
corresponding boundary conditions right
because the other terms look saved in
the Schrodinger equation so now I look
at my this is my X this is my potential
yo I see what would be the wave function
under this constraint the potential
constraint again I'm going to make this
hand waving standing wave requirement I
don't even know I the boundary it has to
be zero in fact it's not exactly zero so
my solution will not be exactly correct
but I'll just say now I still have my
standing half half wave a full way right
and this is at the boundary here this is
my X N and now you say - xn is a half
way must be motor those knots of the way
with the right be the end point where I
is that the boundary constraint has to
are so here I have 2 X n right so that's
the wave must be numb that tends to x n
multiple of 1/2 wait that's my
requirement and what does it it tells me
it tells me X N equals 4 over n H bar H
over X n no X H over P because lambda is
H over P right I change the wave lengths
into momentum okay and now I have with
the from here I have the P so P in terms
of X n I I will just argue that the
kinetic energy of this particle in the
oscillator equals potential energy okay
so that's the what so the kinetic energy
is a P Square to M equals potential
energy 1/2 K x squared right KX n square
P I have the here in terms of X N and
from there I can find out from this I
substitute the P into here I can find
the X n so X n square equals M K and the
NH over 4 and now I go because my this
is my X n my en energy is the kinetic
energy plus potential energy right
I see there you go so the AEI equals KX
n square ok so equals K X n square
and you substitute the in and what I
have is a 4 and H K over m and per my
format is pretty close right if you look
at the harmonic oscillator the real
solution is en is H nu times n so the
point is this quantum number is an in
you're proposing here - yeah right you
see there my potential because of a code
potential constraint it changed my
column quantization is a proportional to
n and in the case of a quantum well this
one you see is a proportional to n
square right you go back to look at your
year in proportion n square in this
shape the yein changing to n and in the
electronic potential that we just
covered here here is 1 over r hn g or
n into the denominator square so my
point is all this problem are really
defined by the potential of the particle
that's the constraint okay and in fact I
try the day electronic I can also make
the same time with an argument I get a 1
over N squared I can get that 13.6
correct but I can get 1 over N square I
haven't found out how I do this
spherical problem gather L plus L times
L plus 1 maybe someone can figure it out
that's an angular momentum problem okay
so ah now we have solution for
translation
we have vibration rotation electronic
for atoms so we almost have everything
right but how once then that's not even
in classical mechanics
and this is the spin it's not a you a in
the Schrodinger equation you have to go
to relativistic consideration to get
that additional spin so I'm not going
into spinning in detail it took me
actually a long time to have some idea
of spin complete quantum okay
so I have legs is a spin right so when
we solve a problem like a rigid rotor we
the rotor is rotating rotating about the
certain axis right that's an angular
rotation that's the classical you have
classical analogy right but see there is
an intrinsic property of any particles
mature waves there and that's an
intrinsic see angular momentum and that
angular momentum is characterized by the
spin and turns out spin of electrons and
photons photons they are different
electron has a half spin and the photons
photons have integral spin and because
of this difference they obey very
different rules okay so let's say
electron spin and the quantum number for
electrons being we use the s and there
are only two one positive one half
negative one 1/2 so those two quantum
numbers you can get it you cannot get it
from straw in Schrodinger equation so
I'll just artificially added in to the
wave function that we see for example
when we consider adding we functioning
from
we'll add an S here okay
that's the important for me to come and
for our photons and photons and later on
photons s is the integral integer one
okay X equal one okay and it turns out
for the half spin are particles this
statistics is very different than the
integer spin of particles and for this
half spin particle we have Pauli
exclusion principle so now if you go to
say my quantum state for that electron
right we just consider the electron
problem the electron I have n L M and
now I add s s equals plus 1/2 of minus
1/2
so I originally for NLM that the G N
squared degeneracy now because of s I
have to and square degeneration
okay so are this one are what the Pauli
exclusion principle say is each quantum
state for this half spin each quantum
state can have maximum
one particle okay so that's the see it
does not apply to fold on doesn't apply
it to fold hung because they have in
their spin but apply to electron each
quantum stay you can only have maximum
one so because of this fold Hong's
electrons they behave very differently
and this electrons is the fermion from
Fermi and photons are bowls on from
Bosse electron unlike each other and
photons photons you can take as many as
1 1 count of state ok so this gives me
for the case fo here right particle or
SI electron you can see the degeneracy
now is GN equals 2 and square it doesn't
change the energy level because of the
spin unless you go to very very detail
but that's fine with just 2 N squared
that's degeneration ok now I've gone
through all this you see what's the use
why are you going through this right so
what do we what do we say starways is
this lecture we want to understand at
least appreciate the energy are
quantized in the mature waves right
electrons translational energy
vibrational energy rotational energy
electronic all those are quantized that
they become discrete and we also
emphasize that depend on the degree of
freedom right we have quantum numbers
and quantum state could be degenerate if
their energy is the same but they are
actually different quantum states they
have the same energy levels
okay so let's go to real work say where
are we observe those quantum effects and
if you look I say how the quantum
mechanics started was actually from a
blackbody radiation and also explaining
the hydrogen spectrum right so
observations okay and very clearly
because the energy levels in the matter
is discrete and that one interact with
the other particles for example of
photon interact with the molecular
electronic energy level right and let's
say the solution we have for the
electronic energy level is negative
thirteen point six and square electron
volts right so N equals one that's one
energy level n equals two is higher so
let's say this is an increase 1 this is
n equals 2
right an increase to and so when a
photon whether photon interact or not
depends on the photon energy matched to
this energy level or not because the
wind I think why electron in hydrogen
the first sit in the lowest energy level
all right and the photon energy if it
comes to match so that it goes to the
next level it gets absorbed right if
it's impotent it doesn't get absorbed if
it's too high doesn't get up though
so what I'll say is you say discrete
absorption lines right and in fact if
you go to check the solar spectrum of
sunlight going through the atom fear you
see many discrete lines and that's
because the atoms have discrete energy
and they absorb full tongue of different
energies
okay so ah that's one example and what I
want to do go next is go to the website
and then let's look at this online
and also periodical table that's fully
merica absorption
okay so let's start first with a solar
spectrum maybe this is a good picture
let's see how good it is
okay here you can see ah this is a
sunlight the I think the this is a
blackbody from the equivalent and the
yellow is outside the atmosphere right
and once you go through the atmosphere
it become very discrete and in this
short wavelength so now you have to
learn how to convert the wavelengths
into energy and wavelength times
frequency in equals speed of light right
so if you know wavelengths you know
frequency and frequency is each new
energy energy if you convert further
into electron volts and why electron
volt is equivalent to 1 point 2 4 micron
okay so that's the so here this is about
one point two four that's where why you
like homework shorter higher energy of
photon longer lower energy right so here
you go to this part it's electronic
because the vibrational energy
rotational energy don't have the high
energy to interact with photon so it's a
it's really the electrons in the
molecule or atom absorb the photon once
you go to here on this side it's a
rotation and vibration rotation is
actually a very small energy and our
vibration is a higher energy so actually
what what the molecule do for example
it's when a vibrate also rotate so
that's why actually it's a depend on
your resolution your equipment if you do
very high resolution you can actually
say discrete lines of rotation vibration
okay and there are many many lines and
there are many species in the atmosphere
they overlap with each other so you can
see that's a it's the quantum mechanic
doesn't have to be going into nano and
it's actually everyday and let's go more
first I want to show those are the
solutions for our day wave function how
the wave function psi and when you do
precise precise complex conjugate what
they really look like N equals 1 is a
sphere right
I think or two you can say it's like a
dumbbell two hot blobs right and this is
a when l equals zero it's a spherical
when l equals 0 M has to be 0 right and
0 0 that's only so and then plus spin
then you have two states let's being s
if I think about electron going into N
equals 1 then n equation one can have a
two quantum state s equals plus minus
1/2 that it hasn't considered right so
this could be two-speed two-stage N
equals 1 N equals 2 is say if I add spin
is 2 n square so equals 8
right equals two so each of this wave
function sphere that's a l cross 0 now I
only cost one that's a p orbital that's
the atomic orbital T optho and when N
equals 3
I have p orbital here and increase
through agency and
three zero zero that's an S orbital this
spherical okay p orbital and then have D
up to D orbital you can say it has a
five wave functions five times two is
ten right so there are ten a possible
quantum states for the D orbital and our
six here to here so what it is bringing
you to this brings you to the periodic
table now let's look at periodic tea
right come to my office you should come
to my office I look like that every day
and the most of time we feel there
should be more atoms there can't find it
right so start from our hydrogen right
one N equals one helium increase one
there to spin up spin down okay so now
let's look at the feeling right so N
equals one
I have hydrogen will be spin up or spin
down English - is he new now the legs n
is 13 point 6 divided by four so it's a
higher a few electron volts higher right
so now I have neom electron increase -
now right perineum so now - n CS equals
s s orbital field right and now I go to
boron carbon so I have boron carbon the
P orbitals 3p orbitals so that can hold
the six more atoms so now you go to here
go to helium so butan my why I say a bit
Ania why helium is so stable because
between here and here is a few electron
volts right that's a large energy
remember KT is 26 milli electron volts
Millie right so it's not active because
it takes a lot of energy for the charge
to go to the next level so fully taken
there okay so you continue so anchor 3
anchor 3 I should have say I have
an inquiry 3 I have P I should have D
right
but since start to change because rather
than D rather than if you the potassium
rather than going here it started with
the the next one they increase for what
happens is to say well the solution I
gave is a one charge one nuclear one
charge right and that we have a lot of
electrons they will interact that
potential will change so the solution
was splitted be another exactly they are
not going exactly to be equal to each
other there are small difference between
those P and D levels and in fact that
they are it turns out the 3d which are
here this is 3d is less say energy then
they say the higher energy then R 4 and
S orbitals so the charge always goes to
lows of the first right and so that's
the day this is those transitional
metals those are the transitional metals
are the D orbital and once you go to
here the F up do comes in ok very
complicated once you go all those say
wave function is complete wave functions
if you do catalysis that this is a C is
something the thermoelectrics people
look into this all the time ok so I will
stop here and the pretty much with this
through lecture I went through the
quantum mechanics
you